[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le jour où je l'ai rencontré dans une de
ces soirées j'ai même pas pu la regarder
tellement ses yeux me brûlaient alors je
lui ai pris la main les yeux le corps et
les seins elle me dit fais-moi du bien
je lui dis oui sans problème dans sa
chambre on est allé sous les drap on
s'est glissé il a fallu me ranimer dans
ses yeux je m'étais noyé et elle se sert
tout contre moi je me crois au cinéma je
me prends pour caré grandante et puis on
éteint la lampe j'ai perdu la tête
depuis que j'ai vu
suusette je perds la raison chaque fois
que je vois suison j'ai perdu la tête
depuis que j'ai vu Suzette je fa la
raison chaque fois que je m
suuson je ne fais que d'embrasser cette
filleelà me fait rêver elle a vraiment
quelque chose salut bien sûrement des
roses un seul de ses baisés pe suffire à
enflammer le cœur de l'humanité
ou les gars de mon quartier elle a un
petit coup d'orangeer de miel et de
chocolat elle a douci mon errance avant
je n'existais pas toute la salive que j'
pour me donner de l'éclat elle a pas ça
m'amuser pour mettre le monde dans les
mois l'amour est la vérité l'ivresse et
puis la beauté tout ce qu'en vain je
cherché dans ces lieux je l'ai trouvé
[Musique]
ouais j'ai perdu la tête depuis que
Jésus suette je pers la raison chaque
fois que je vois suon ouis j'ai perdu la
tête depuis que j'ai vu Suzette je la
raison chaque fois que je voison
ouis